[Applaudissements]
jean pancartes et discours les opposants
sont toujours décidés à faire bloc
contre le futur du campus de grignon
destiné à devenir un projet immobilier
on n'arrive toujours pas à se faire
entendre on a écrit au ministère
concerné au ministère des finances au
ministère de l'agriculture et au
ministère de l'environnement et nous
n'avons toujours pas de réponse on avait
constaté une illégalité dans la
procédure de vente et que donc on allait
déposer un recours au tribunal
administratif
le nom de l'acquéreur a été révélée cet
été par l'état altéra un promoteur
immobilier français spécialisé dans le
secteur du logement des bureaux et du
commerce une décision qui a fédéré de
nombreux élus du territoire dans le camp
des opposants à de maintes reprises nous
avons alerté les ministres concernés le
gouvernement du fait que ce projet ne
pouvait pas être menées ni sont les élus
ni sur le monde agricole j'ai rencontré
julien normandie sur plein de sujets
cette semaine qui m'a dit qu'il était en
train de me répondre je crains que ce
soit un peu tard à noter aussi la
présence de yannick jadot et de delphine
batho députée des deux sèvres et ans
ministre de l'écologie j'ai signé de
nombreux courriers avec les autres élus
j'ai soutenu les étudiants qui avaient
bloqué l'école et la décision qu'a pris
le ministre de l'agriculture parce que
c'est lui est absolument scandaleuse on
est dans un moment où on est confronté
au plus grand défi de l'histoire de
l'humanité on peut encore l'empêcher
puisque c'est pas signé près de 400
personnes ont été dénombrées par les
forces de l'ordre une lettre a été
envoyée aux différents ministres le 30
août dernier ils ont deux mois pour leur
répond